vous le savez nous n'avons pas le droit
de publier deux modèles avant le 26 août
aussi avons nous demandé à la mariée de
la collection d'yves saint laurent de
nous prêter son joli visage pour servir
de décor yves saint laurent vous venez
de faire une collection particulièrement
réussie je vous fera oublier une
question la silhouette de la femme
moderne n'a pas cessé d'évoluer de la
tête aux pieds depuis 20 ans c'est à
dire que celle de 67 ne ressemble en
rien à ces deux 47 pas plus qu'à celle
de 27
est-ce que vous pensez que nous soyons
arrivés à une sorte de stabilisation de
la mode féminine
oui certainement je pense en tout cas
qu'il arrive de plus en plus à travers
chaque collection je pense que la vie
moderne a tellement évolué et que tout a
tellement changé que les femmes n'ont
plus envie de se trouver transformé par
une silhouette différente chaque saison
et mêmes d'année en année je pense que
c'est une chose plus stable que la mode
est arrivé à une chose puis stable je
trouve que c'est bien mieux parce que ça
permet de voir affirmé le style des
couturiers avant l'heure alors qu'avant
c'était davantage d'hésiter des défauts
l'icwa tandis que la halle un style
demeure et s'affirme chaque année parler
de folie il ya tout de même question
très importante c'est celle de la
longueur des jupes 40 on ne peut pas
dire que dans la rue la femme soit
tellement élégante au sens où vous
l'entendez
jusqu'à maintenant c'est à dire que le
mot élégant a tellement changé aussi
l'une des cinq plus du tout dire la même
chose que qu'avant la guerre ou même
qu'aux qu'il ya dix ans je pense que le
mot élégant et qui est remplacé par le
mot séduisant je crois qu'on a davantage
envie d'être séduit tant que d'être
élégant maintenant
vous m'avez dit que c'était pas
tellement je dise qu'on voyait dans la
rue tout un art mais c'est à dire il ya
le meilleur et le pire
en tout cas moi je suis pour l'est pour
les robes courtes y fait ce que vous
voulez me faire dire évidemment tout est
une question d'âge et de femmes même
c'est pas seulement d'âge mais de femmes
haussier en tout cas je pense que c'est
une chose qui restera encore un arrêt
très longtemps